(punk rock)
(awkward dancing as rock continues)
(darkiplier arises)
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and I'm very dizzy ahhhh  Xp
I was ready for that (That's what she said)
welcome to peace death now this game :)
which probably has the cool soundtrack(rocks out)
that I've seen - Milo okay I don't know...........
these OH HI so this is a game because
you guys presented the conundrum that I,
find moral choices in games very
difficult when it comes to being a judge :<
jury and executioner but this game in
particular CHAIR!?!?! oh but you're going for
the CHAIR there Ohhhh nooo.....
(tumbleweed passes by causually)
(ALARM)
(markimoo gets idea)
okay alright then
yeah...... okay....uh  huh oh....... I see...
this is funny because this game is
executing itself like a very specific
SCP it's *chuckles* weird like uh.. and that'll make
sense if you ever read the SCP about it
there's a certain SCP that you CANNOT
WRITE,THINK or TALK about in ANYWAY
only way you can get information about
it across is through symbols and
suggestions because otherwise OH HI!! :0
otherwise it'll come get you that's what
it'll do welcome to apocalypse.inc,Reaper....
I'm your Superior LOOK AROUND!! and get
down to work.... AH you gluttony ah you own
guard it's the plague doctor!!!! :D from SCP
wouldn't you know it!! (mark brags) I called this shit!!
okay.... what do I do..???
AHHH.... junior apprentice 30 client I don't
know how well I know I'm doing here so I
got a lot of Pez, coins...I don't know
OH HI it is your first day today Reaper
so here is a simple task that you won't
screw up!! okay.. alrighty then...
Devil's must be sent to the left
elevator to HELL people must be sent to
the rrrrright one to heaven! :) now go ahead oh
sh.. sh..sure "can I take my axe with me" sure go
ahead!!! :) your doing great!! AH NAH DOOM :<
HELLO!!!
I think I'm doing great... heh..(doubt) "hurt me" okay :)
Ok will do! okay "I'm important cargo" oh it's
funny!!! okay... okay.. okay I did it!!! I did
great!!! :
I did great!!!! I did good!!!!! :) I actually did
good guys!!!! yeah!!! oh.... did the Four Horsemen
of the Apocalypse.....
I didn't even know that was possible...
HI Jack(septiplier) what are you doing here!!*chuckle* you all
right??.... Jack! yeah okay
hello? did I save you..... think maybe I did...
all right. one time effects Authority
additional influence it's except for chosen
horsemen.. why I dont even know what these are..I DONT KNOW WHAT ANY OF THIS IS!!!...
was thrust into a job that apparently
I'm incredible and I don't think I
wanted :< all right you know what I'm going
to..... yeah! I'll do that one. yeah! that
sounds good to me and m.m..maybe okay all
right... you know I'm gonna go for it!!! huh?
today other Reapers noticed a funny
thing and that's what I say Reaper
trying to send his demonic desmosomes to
heaven Lucifer began to endow people
with his demonic power in horns
from this day on everyone who wears a
horn should be sent to HELL
good(weird sound) okay... goodbye! all right! okay, okay oh..
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy(cunfuzzeled mark)
oh boy oh boy.. okay! I don't have good
commentary im just sayin' "OH BOY" over and over
again.... goodbye
See yaa I wish I could see what these
guys are saying to me the meaning of
life is to serve humanity
oh no "save me from the Marines" now you
go back in there! oh okay okay okay okay
okay!!! all right!!! yeah!!!!!!!! I did it I'm amazing(marks ego grows larger)
I'm really good at this :)
I'm actually really I..I.. actually do like
these sort of things because I'm good at
pattern recognition that's one of the
things that I'm very good at about with
names I'm bad with remembering
short-term stuff but a pattern
recognition whoo hoo boy bebe are in
that shit
whoo that's all over my bag oh hey "200
years ago I invented a substance for
poisoning cockroaches but it's hand out
quite differently from what I expected I
instead of killing them.... it's reagent
made cockroaches grow.... and these giants
are now destroying the city doing Wars
job I need to deal with it as soon as
possible work the next day for me and
save my reputation... today I shouldn't be
distracted reward... after work..." okay cool...
war,war never changes I know myself I'm
100 and vegan adore broccoli with meat
without the broccoli(mark sounds) huh I'm not the
worst that can happen to men..... okay right
cool I think :< each client is one less
feature level of 60 seconds longer
i don't need that
not a boink oh I clicked in the wrong
spot for that okay.... yeah.. sure... okay! all
right let's do this
today people starting to use weapons
Reaper! just today it was the craziest
thing who had thought it!!! (i did)
certainly not I
weapons are those dangerous things they
have with them the way to heaven is
closed for them as famines mouth is
closed for healthy food then everyone
who gets you with fire armor ebbed
weapons to HELL... let's begin okay goodbye
hello goodbye goodbye alright you know
thank you!! okay I still got to remember
all just a game of Simon Says isn't it
no yep yeah no no no can you get out of
here with your weapons!!
no with your horns!!!! you're fine... get in
there that's this weird.... you know go to
hell you gonna hell you're gonna hell
you go to heaven man the people go into
having her a lot less these days you
know he'll go to hell cave man go to hell
go to hell go to hell go to hell again
gonna hell fuck no one's going to having
these days it's not a single goddamn
person's going to heaven at least I
gotta work for pestilence they're the
"fear of many people living on the planet
has come to live the British scientist
working on a cure against influenza made
a mistake no doubt with pestilence has
helped and invented not what they wanted
it now London is steeped in a thick fog
and it is habited with zombies but it's
not too late reaper bidden yet
non-mutated people still will be saved
or rather the mutation will be postponed
he caught up with some Kyle crane fellow
he needs our help in transporting the
working antidote we can't deliver it
ourselves but there is one fearless
courier service that is willing to
knew the gentleman it'll cost a bit of
money what do you say?...." Ahhh but why??
reputation go down?? :/ oh if I deny it
Ah okay(mark has self doubt) I don't know if there's a good
deal but sure...... "it's for all our sakes
thank you...."  uh..okay, I don't know what I
agreed to but okay :< all right you know
I'm just gonna go for it cuz I got
plenty of money and I alright
"do you know Reaper that an average
person is up to five liters of blood
some have it on themselves by the way in
order not to stain the white and pure
heaven those who are covered in blood
should be sent to hell..
let's begin..." okay go ahead
No thank you no  nah ah that's all right
you're not okay here go go go oh my god
I don't know why the purity of heaven
would be ruined by someone with blood it
could be.. all right you go..(mark noises) another
tough call there!! tough call!! all right
get here skadotalee get it Lee
skadotalee (x2)
no yep yep nope go go go go
yep that almost looked like blood I
wasn't sure about that.. OH BOY I got
to remember everything one of these bad
boys
oh NOO!!! oh NOO!!! im not feeling it!!
GO AWAY :<.... whooooooo boy.....
God is getting harder and harder as time
goes on who'd have thought that a game
would be that way!! (NO WAY :0) heyyy I'm a senior
apprentice... I don't know how many ranks
arrow to climb but I'm gonna do one mo
of these.... lets do war "feel the fury of my
beard!!!"  okay.. all right.. you don't have
anything for me :< ah this is him "haha
awesome
you know what is happening the
Confederates are concluding the truce
with the Federals and that's who our
advantage Reaper for the war for the
conflict will end in war will remain out
of work
but at the same time there's a
super-duper giant meteor flying to earth
to the same region I don't propose to
stop it because catastrophes are always
fun but we need to slow it down as much
as possible to make the meteor fall after
peace truce is signed as the loss is in
the result of such an event are not as
great as from the long war would you
like to buy front-row tickets to this
amazing show the contributions will be
sent to chromeless to create local time
dilation" ahhhhh unfortunately I don't have
the money for that so sorry.... insult to
you.. ahh yeah sorry about that
I don't need these do this again hats and
headgear save the cold in the wind but
here has hinder our right decisions
everyone who comes here can use hats
side horns and horns or a feature of
hell take off hats from clients to make
sure you can make the right decision
you're day begins!!!! again okay no yeah sure
yeah take off people's hats how am I
supposed to do that
Oh take off your hat no alright you
gotta go anyway you got blood anyway
excuse me get a de Leeuw doodly-doo go i
saw a weapon there NOPE
alright you're fine nope yep no nope
NOT TODAY!!!
what that doesn't count in the Hat the
hood count as a hat!!(in school it does mark) OH WHATS THAT
Oh!!! get out here you!!! no no no no weapons
none of that! you're fine somewheres
wheres are rather well with that no go go
go oh you're fine hey.... I did it
actually pretty good at this they
liking this  not bad okay but anyway let me
finish out the week let me finish out
the week.. "in the name of the Lich King
your eagerness to work knows no bounds"
okay I'm gonna finish out the week here
one of the bloodiest days reaper,is today....
there's so much blood so you need to
look everywhere even at the feet puddles
the blood left by the sinners are a
clear sign of the bad intentions
so the hell is they belong... let's begin
also get ready for unexpected
catastrophes reaches there's a time
limit you'll figure it out"
okay I'll go ahead no oh what's under
there no I see the blood nope No
what's gonna be easy if everyone's just
gonna hell already no no no yeah you're
fine you're fine you're fine
Oh No Oh what's under there doesn't
matter anyway I saw the blood oh no
Louis dicks on Jack the buzzer ripped it
off a cliff
what am I mean Oh No!!!!!!!
uh you're fine again yep yep oh no no
i made it goof!!!!!!
oh my first goof I can't believe it oh
man.... alright fine man
oh boy I had a perfect record  ahhhhhh I saw it
like a second too late ah man
"reaper,it's a nightmare tomorrow there's a
symposium on deadly diseases and I am
invited as the sole honorary lecturer
because no one can compete with my
intelligence and nobody else understands
old diseases as they do but the fact is
that I need someone to stay here would
you help me and work the next day for me?"
sure! silence will help you,reaper,
reward after work"
look okay I don't know what
that means but I'm gonna go and finish
out the week your first weekend Reaper so
you work on weekends today we have a
surprise for you a theme day use your
accumulated knowledge surrounding by the
inhabitants of ancient Egypt and do your
job properly
go ahead all right oh..... okay
right you're fine also fine also fine
what's in the Hat now I see the Blood
go cool okay this is gonna be a bit
is  that a Hat *chuckles* i guess its a hat. okay I get blood
okay no blood oh kay  go go okay no idea what
something ohhhh you tried to sneak that one
you're fine but you're trying to sneak
it on me! not to talk man. ahhhhh noooo I thought i saw
too late Oh on a goof Xp Fine man get out of
here go God spot less record what is
that a hat okay no! all right you're fine
put her bird god you're fine you're not
fine you're not fine god dammit I was
gonna have a perfect week I got lazy on
the weekends(dont we all..we all eat ramen)
I'm a detective though so anyway OH HI
oh good good good good good good good
okay all right okay... guess I got that I
i did all right :<
FINE! but anyway that is peace death an
interesting game a game of conscious and
quick wit and lightning reflexes which I
almost have! even though like it's always
like a second lay the brain doesn't
register it but either way that was fun
so let me know what you think I did down
in the comments below maybe I'm just
barely above average or even average as
a bit but thanks again
and as always i will see you in the next
video bye bye
(outro music)